stephanie berry is a busy mother of four
so when she woke up with a headache and
a sore throat she quickly reached for a
rapid test so i did it up my nose and it
came back negative so i'm like okay no
big deal i went about my day
um i got worse as the day progressed a
search online brought up throat swabbing
a common practice in the uk wipe the
soft tip of the swab around the back of
the throat i did throat like you know
the four or five times on your tongue
and then on your cheeks and then up my
nose five times and it came back
positive like within a minute a small
pre-print study out wednesday found
nasal rapid antigen tests leg when it
comes to catching covet early last month
a larger trial out of south africa
called nasal testing suboptimal when it
came to the omicron variant specifically
epidemiologist eric feigle ding says
this is likely because it replicates
much quicker in the upper respiratory
tract it's a very different virus from
delta and it seems that you can find it
not only more but also find it about a
day earlier
if you swab your mouth but officials
aren't ready to make formal
recommendations the us fda instead
issued a safety warning this week and
implored americans to follow their rapid
test kit instructions health canada
approves the inserts for at home rapid
tests here most advised nasal swabs and
while the public health agency wouldn't
say if it would be issuing new
guidelines toronto er doctor kashif
persona says the government needs to
make adjustments as the virus changes
it's time to be a bit more proactive
like every house should have a box of
these rapid tests your throat i think
should probably be standard now he says
swabbing your throat and your nose
wouldn't invalidate the results just
make sure you're doing it correctly
for any mouth sampling do not drink or
eat about 30 minutes before you do the
sample barry is relieved she found she
was positive before her husband a
firefighter went to work and her kids
went to daycare i'm just like i'm
worried for how many people have
protected in their nose and then have
gone and done whatever thinking they're
negative the last thing any of us want
to unknowingly risk infecting others
jamie morocco global news toronto